vanessa bryant continues her case in
court seeking justice for her late
husband kobe bryant and daughter gianna
who were killed in a 2020 helicopter
crash
on friday vanessa emotionally testified
detailing her life and trauma since the
accident
we love and miss you boo boo and gigi
according to cnn while vanessa was on
the witness stand she claimed she
experiences panic attacks and anxiety
over possibly seeing photos from the
accident the outlet reports that vanessa
recalled the day she got the
heartbreaking news
quote i bolted out of the house and i
ran to the side of the house so the
girls couldn't see me i wanted to run
down the block and just scream i can't
escape my body i can't escape what i
feel
she's suing the la sheriffs and fire
department over photos taken at the
tragic scene that were shared for
personal use
and on the stand vanessa recalled her
interaction with authorities
after sheriff alex villanueva informed
her that kobe and gigi died vanessa said
he asked her if there was anything he
could do her response quote if you can't
bring my babies back then please secure
the area i'm concerned about paparazzi
vanessa claims sheriff villanueva
assured her that he would honor her
request and informed her that he secured
a temporary flight restriction over the
area
e.t has reached out to vanessa's legal
team for comment
in a dramatic opening statement her
attorney claimed law enforcement
exploited the accident by taking and
sharing pictures of kobe and gianna as
souvenirs
former fire captain brian jordan took
the stand to testify on monday but
walked off the witness stand three times
citing stress from working the crash as
his reason for repeatedly excusing
himself
attorney also told jurors the photos
were virtual gossip and played security
video of an off-duty sheriff's deputy
showing them to a bartender to support
that claim
sheriff's deputy joey cruz is the
officer in question he's accused of
sharing photos at the scene cruz
admitted he took it too far and said
it's something i shouldn't have done
meanwhile kobe's widow is receiving an
outpour of love from family and friends
including the late nba star's former
teammate shaquille o'neal who expressed
to e.t his empathy for vanessa
i couldn't imagine what she's going
through
we live in a world where
especially when it hits the internet
people don't care but
those aren't pictures that i would ever
ever want to see so
you know she's doing a great thing for
you know how many people as possible
you